any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
welcome everybody to the into the
impossible podcast a production of the
arthur c clark center for human
imagination at uc san diego
i am your fearful host brian keating
co-director of the arthur c clarke
center for human imagination
today is a very special episode for me
not only do i get to interview
one of my colleagues in my field of
cosmology but the very person who
inspired me to write my own book losing
the nobel prize
a story of cosmology ambition and the
perils of science's highest honor
and that's stephane alexander and he
more than any person really
uh is credited in some way or maybe
blamed
for encouraging me to write this book
and
i want to read from the acknowledgments
of my book where
i refer to him and the deep impact he
had on my life
i say this book owes his existence to my
brother from another mother stephen
alexander
nothing has changed between us since
those late night intellectual jam
sessions spent together as nobel
hopefuls at brown university 25 years
ago
then as now stefan's encouragement and
wisdom kept me going through the
darkness
thank you for believing that mine was a
story that needed to be told
and i've known stefan since we were both
beginning graduate students at brown
university where he now teaches
and stefan is actually also in addition
to his teaching and theoretical
and contributions in research he is the
president of the national society of
black physicists a member
for many decades and now he leads that
organization i'm
proud to say that i'm also an honorary
member
of that august organization and i hope
that my listeners out there will take
this opportunity to
visit nsbp.org and uh perhaps if the
spirit moves you make a donation
in honor of the many contributions to
our knowledge of the universe that these
incredible minds have made uh today's
episode's very special because
as i said it's with one of my friends
and how often do you get to interview
your friends
we're going to talk a lot about stefan's
book the jazz of physics
subtitle is the secret link between
music and the structure of the universe
this copy if you're watching the video
is actually the
first copy that he ever got and i was
with him in new york
in early 2016 right before it came out
it's the fourth anniversary
and the dedication still moves me it
says he wrote to me to my best friend
brian 23 years after that cold night
with the sacks at the bridge
we have arrived looking forward to your
book and this is before i even thought
about writing a book
so stefan uh is a tremendous influence
on me and my life and this has
uh really been uh just such a pleasure
to
watch as he's influenced the careers of
many generations of physicists
and will continue to do so as the
president of the national society of
black physicists
so i encourage everybody to get this
book uh you'll stay tuned you'll hear
some
some call outs to his upcoming work and
i
urge you to tune in and see all the
great stuff that stefan is doing
now please enjoy this episode featuring
professor stefan alexander
uh welcome everybody to the latest
edition
of the into the impossible podcast a
production
of the arthur c clarke center for human
imagination
at ucsd i'm your fearful host during
these pandemic podcasts my name is brian
keating i'm the associate director of
the clark center
and uh all the podcasts that i've done i
think i've
done about 20 by now since the pandemic
started to take over the planet back in
in march and uh of all of those podcasts
i have to say that this is the one
perhaps i've been looking forward to
the most simply because the guest today
is
uh none other than my uh my best buddy
uh stefan alexander
who uh who's really been a fixture in my
life
for what i don't want to say it's
probably close to three decades now but
let's not get into how old we each are
he's older than me he is older than me
by a couple of months he's
wiser wiser than me too
so i want to introduce stefan alexander
professor stefan alexander
who is professor of physics at brown
university stefan
welcome to the into the impossible
podcast
well brian um i am i remain
flattened as flat as flat earth
[Laughter]
flattered than flatter earth i never
thought i never i would never imagine
like you know you know many decades ago
um
me going on that dangerous fir airplane
flight with you when you learn how to
fly
today would come where you you would be
interviewing me on a podcast
yeah i know it would be uh quite crazy
to think of either one and
for us both to be professors uh although
i i had high hopes for you i wasn't so
sure about myself
but um but it's really a treat to have
on uh such a good friend on this podcast
and i also want to thank you
uh and express gratitude for connecting
me to so many brilliant minds as you
have that have been guests on the
podcast and
looking forward to uh to many more and
the other thing i want to thank you for
is uh is inspiring me to write my book
losing the nobel prize
which above my different shoulders here
are various
pictures of the cover the audiobook and
the regular book and in that
in the acknowledgement section you were
the person that i thank first so i
i don't thank my mother for having me uh
until later
but i thank you because you really not
only
convinced me that i had a story worthy
of telling but you showed the way
forward in your book the jazz of physics
which we're going to get into
on the anniversary of its fourth
anniversary of its publication i cannot
believe
that time has flown by and it has been
four years can you believe what is it
how does it feel does it feel like it
just came out yesterday
it literally it does feel like it came
out but two days ago
um but but yeah and then you know it's
funny
um you know when i think about like good
friendships throughout my lifetime
it's those that that have organically
been
that of like you know i think this sort
of
this this sort of like you know yeah you
have a lot
you have things to be grateful but i
also have things very
um um powerful things to be grateful of
uh to you of you know so it goes
both ways so maybe one day if i if i
chance on a podcast i'll
i'll also um about what those things are
right
yeah maybe when your next performance at
uh jazz at carnegie lincoln center
definitely i definitely am thankful for
that that tasted watch i got for the you
know oh yeah
for being in the wedding right though
that's right am i one of my best men at
my wedding that's right
absolutely i cannot believe that's been
almost 12 years ago while i'm sitting
here enjoying and every time
i gave you that watch because i wanted
you to every time you look at it to
think of how much you mean to me and how
much
hopefully i've come to mean to you in
the decade there and then
and plus since i got married and gave
you that gift for your service as a
the honor guard at my wedding uh but
every time i have a cup of this
substance here which is not vodka for a
change it is uh simply coffee
i uh i think about you because you were
the first person to introduce me to
coffee as we call it we new yorkers
you remember our oceans coffee roasters
right oh yeah man that's
uh that that that was a fixture for us
in graduation you took me there you got
me hooked on coffee
and i'll i'll never really contemplate
seeing you without a cup of coffee
not too uh far away from you and that's
not surprising because as
the mathematician pearl erdos said that
a mathematician is a machine to convert
coffee
into equations and you are a theoretical
physicist
with a specialization in early universe
cosmology
and you and i both study together on the
different
polls of experiment and theory way back
beginning in 1993
at brown university and uh
oh yeah and i want to take us back to
those uh
to those heady days in the early part of
the or the late
at part of the previous millennium i it
makes it sound really old let me talk
like that
but i want to talk about um how our
careers have kind of
been mirror images of one another you
pursuing uh
theoretical pursuits in cosmology and
mine and experimental but kind of
loosely coupled like cooper pairs
uh across the uh the brillouin sphere or
something like that
uh none other than leon cooper your
colleague our former professor
at uh at brown university who is he
still is he emeritus now what is leon's
uh status quo
his mind is sharp is still sharp as heck
does not surprise me
you know obviously i have cooper stories
for days there's a cooper story in
chapter three of the book of course
that's right now he never fails to you
know
to just like you know throw me off guard
right that's what he's good at
and so i'll never forget um
we were taken as advanced quantum mach
mechanics i don't know if you remember
this but i was in that class of course
you were with me yeah we were in that
class
i barely could handle regular quantum
mechanics and here he was
and um i remember him saying so i asked
a question and he's like
well you obviously didn't pay attention
in your undergraduate quantum mechanics
class
and i was half tempted to say well i
learned undergraduate quantum mechanics
from your book
but i didn't say i didn't have the um
can you imagine that
i don't even think leon would he would
have smacked me upside down that would
other quantum professors
and i won't name names no no we're not
going to go there
no no we're not going to go there but
the audience knows who leon cooper is
right
yeah tell us about him tell us about him
what does he mean what does he mean to
physics
um well you know there's a you know
almost 50 or a problem called
superconductivity that was actually
right
experimental it's a 1911 i can't omnis
i guess i pronounced the name camera
lenon yeah
discovered experimentally that metals
you know um will
you know conduct with zero resistance
and there was no explanation for it
theoretically
and everybody worked on it including
einstein feynman
landau you name it schrodinger
heisenberg um and a very young guy named
leon cooper
and the important thing about leon was
he was an outsider so he was trained as
a particle physicist
you know you know a new yorker like us
yeah and um baudeen took him out to
illinois and bardeen actually literally
wanted um you know
somebody that was not a condensed matter
person to work on the problem because
he felt that they would have fresh eyes
and an outsider's perspective
and it proved to be correct um and you
know
um the important thing about leon
is he is um you know
he basically took that what 17-hour
train ride from illinois back to new
york
and decided to just he tried all these
calculations and say you know what
i'm just gonna like see the problem as a
physics problem and just like throw away
the math and just like
you know just do some dirty physics use
my intuition
and he cracked the code he solved
supercomp you know he came up with a key
idea
which is that fermions can pair up to
to act as a quasi kind of you know
basically effectively act as a spin zero
particle
um that enabled this collective effect
such that
that collective effect of the spin zero
particle could conduct
um without any um resistance and it led
to some predictions and
earned him a nobel prize and one of the
things leon always used to tell me
whenever
i he would make me feel stupid he said
um you know
einstein once told me i was like okay he
goes
that um if if we knew what we were
talking about we wouldn't call it
research
yep yeah that was one of his chestnuts
yeah and like one one one other
interesting i think very powerful leon
cooper's story i think that really
kind of um in kind is
is my lantern all right for how i do
things and how i
do everything in my in my work um
including my mentor and of students
one time after 15 years i i figured that
you know that i was gonna come back
and like impress him you know like i had
already been a young professor i just
got on tenure
i got this fancy you know aps award and
all this whatever right
um and i drive back and leon is there
he's just about to retire i go in his
office
and i start getting a blackboard and i
at this point i figured i
knew all this like all this math and all
the stuff sitting there
and by the time i i'd written this paper
with michael peskin that was like a
prl and it was like a big thing for us
and i write this thing and he goes you
know stefan you just slow down
i mean you know i think i'm a pretty
smart guy but you just gotta slow down
and i'm like
wow you know it's like he set me up for
the sucker punch i'm like oh wow like
leon is like you know
i'm i'm going too fast to the master so
then he goes
and you know why don't you find a real
problem and like work on it
like find find yourself a real problem
like a hard problem
like a real physics problem and like
dedicate yourself and work on it
and i was like you know i've you know
it was like the death blow of those kung
fu movies like only three days later you
start like you know
having internal bleeding and like
yeah like i've been wasting 15 years of
my time like you know chasing
whatever yeah chasing you know
chasing the company basically right yeah
identify my problem like you know and
actually i thought about you because you
had been
you as an experimentalist i call you
you know a theoretical experimentalist
um
had been had been chasing that right you
had been doing that for decades
yeah i think i was talking about this
with jenna levin who you connected me
with
uh on the podcast recently and i said
you know physicists uh
sort of have to cultivate a brand like
what their tastes are
and i think you exemplify that um
as well as and i hope we can get into
this as well um not just within the
research domain
where you're you know eminently you know
successful in your research program
of coming up with a brand the alexander
brand which has a characteristic style
which is different you know than someone
like janna who will write
no very well on fordham road alexander's
that's right
and uh but but on the same token having
you know having a very
disciplined approach to to research but
also being able to communicate
ideas to a lay audience and uh and i
think exemplified in
in this book how you really have an
ability which
which i you know as i discussed with her
there aren't so many people
like her like you who can both
communicate to
to the layperson but also can uh can do
cutting-edge research and there are
people like
our our friend neil degrasse tyson who
is you know an amazing
communicator you know very polished you
know he's uh
he's he's phenomenal what he does uh but
he's not doing cutting-edge scientific
research and he's the first to admit it
which which is one of the things that
endears me endears him to me so much
because he will be
you know the first to say well there's a
big discovery of the black hole event
horizon
you know and the media will want to talk
to him and he'll say no go talk to the
team that did it
go talk to the real scientist um and i
and i
have great respect for that but how do
you straddle and how do you manage that
and
and is it is it you know what's your
workflow like to go
can you slip in and out of these two
different um very highly creative
modalities of thought one i think you
would agree right that
theoretical physics is incredibly
creative and so is jazz music
and improvisation and also writing so
take us through those three different
um you know kind of uh tripartite
aspects of your
of your nature well i'm gonna be
i'll i'll probably be the first this
will probably be the first time i admit
this
on any podcast i've done a few since
writing my book and
exclusive exclusive to the into the
impossible podcast yeah so i would say
like internally i don't
i don't actually feel that like you know
when we think about the classic being
smart like you know this person
can you know accumulate information
or you know can it could master these
technical things or
i've always felt like and like i i don't
feel
smart in that way right and what
i've managed to do i think my hack
is i've managed to
um engage in things that i'm naturally i
would say i'm naturally
attuned to um attracted to
and figured out a way to weave them into
each other in a way that if you cut one
of those
one of those links they all fall apart
so for example
you know you um you know that i you know
i i used to
i was a serious runner and i until until
i you know
400 meters right i turned 49.
now it's 399 meters that's right you
know 400 and 800 and cross country and
like so i was really into that
but a lot of times i found that my runs
was exactly that place going on that
hour long run
where i can really get deep into a
problem and just like
be um not have the um the self editing
that would come out of just
if you're sitting at a desk right
because you're running you're not going
to be editing yourself too much
right you got to not worry about not
slipping on ice um
and or like you know my music right so
and then my
my physics they're all they're kind of
like one activity lends itself to the
other
such that if i stop one i will feel it
you know i will see a negative effect
with the others so i've kind of come up
with a system for myself
where i'm the kind of like you know jack
of those trades and
really i don't feel like i'm a master of
any of those right um
and and those three things they cycle
between each other there are days where
i'll probably play
practice more these days i'm practicing
more um
my saxophone and you know studying my
music and some days i'll
be thinking more about a physics problem
other days i might be i might be
writing but they're usually all
integrated with each other
and if like you cut one of those things
off the others will suffer
so that's a balance between those two
but it takes
um i mean how i always see it and i've
heard it
written that the human brain is actually
not as good as we think about
multitasking
and you know especially when things are
very disparate like you know
it's one thing to be writing an email or
something and then you know turn your
attention to writing a latex
you know code for a paper uh but it's
another thing to be you know practicing
you know i don't know what you guys do
and jazz musicians but
you must do scales or something like
that and then go and sit down and write
down you know a
two-dimensional ising model you know
expansion as applied to some you know
very uh intricate calculation in in
theoretical physics uh
can you do that or is it more like well
one day i'll spend time on writing and
uh and the other time i'll you know and
then a day later or some
other half of the day i'll do you know
jazz or do
uh hardcore physics how do you approach
it is it separated in time or space or
both
yeah they're separating time and i don't
multitask um i
i'm unlike um our friend jim gates he
claims to be a really good multitasker i
you know i i'm i'm horrible at that
um i'm very bad at uni-tasking i mean
like he's working on one thing
um but um but i guess let me
let's see um so i think one of the
things that i found happening is that
i'll be working up thinking about a
physics problem actually i'll be
thinking about
thinking about a problem i'll be
thinking about like what kind of problem
is worthy pursuing or are there problems
to work on right so sometimes be as
simple as like
what should we be working should i be
working on
you know what's not already been done
what are the low-hanging fruits right
just a strategy of even finding a
problem
you know um i actually want to turn that
question back to you
uh when i'm done saying what i have to
say and sometimes
and sometimes you know like i'm i i
hate to admit this but i'm an impatient
person and because i'm impatient
what ends up happening is i get very
frustrated and then i i stifle my own
creative and even technical uh
you know abilities so
a simple act of going off and doing
something else
that is com that might might be apparent
appear to be orthogonal
to that mode right so if i go play my
sax and i just like
work on a scale or work on you know a
cadence or whatever
a tude or whatever right um
long blown blown long tones and facing
the wall with saxophone and just
blown a long note for like as long as
you can and just repeating that for over
and over again
there's something about doing that about
kind of
vacillating between those things that
kind of i don't know like
contributes i don't know the right word
is but i i don't clear i don't i don't
want to claim that there's a flash of
genius or insight
but somehow like at least it gives me a
little bit more energy or you know
my patient tank fills up a little bit
more so i'm able to go back to that
problem or go back to that
confusion and look at it with fresh eyes
um and so so for me it's important to
have these other
hobbies or things that i do that appear
to be orthogonal to
to you know to each other um and i found
that
um to be also the case for some other
friends i mean you're a pilot so i was
wondering if like a similar thing
happens to you
yeah i think there's different aspects
of it where you can help to enter
into what your colleague at brown
university judd brewer who's an
addiction psychologist and
a psychiatrist md phd
and he talks about this flow state and
how people have gotten into it
and obviously it's it's it's a it's a
state of extreme
pleasure once one is inside of such a
state
and he talks about how you know you can
kind of pre-game
the brain to be receptive to do so to
in order to do practical things so it's
you know creativity of a physics
equation that describes you know
10-dimensional space-time
might not have very many applications in
the real world of any but
uh but if you're struggling with you
know smoking addiction
uh he will then recommend to you this
exploration
of the curious mind this the state of
flow that is sort of
engaged by the parallel trait of
curiosity which is
you know as far as we know the way that
we express creative curiosity is unique
on on among species and uh and i think
it's
so too is it you know possible to get
into a flow state where
you are you know kind of concentrating
and time is slipping by and you're not
noticing it yeah so for me flying a
plane
that could do it because you have to
concentrate so
strongly and intently on that task yeah
except when i flew you over
you know rhode island sound uh back way
back when and
we had some uh we had some interesting
interesting experiences didn't we
but um but i want to you know kind of
take this the next step which is you
know on the arthur c clarke center's you
know podcast uh
into the impossible we like to talk
about
how can you actually train the mind
train for
curiosity and stimulate the mind to do
these things
and is it possible or is it really
fundamentally different the type of
creativity that you have
as a saxophonist versus the creativity
that you have as a
as a jazz musician obviously the jazz of
physics makes a case that
there are commonalities between the two
but let's take it a step further are
you know is there a commonality with
experimental physics
um you know is it is it the zen in the
art of motorcycle maintenance or is
there something
endemic to the art of experimental
science
um you know versus theoretical science
it's just different that
no it's not possible to get the same
kind of flow state or whatever as an
experimentalist as a theorist would
explore
yeah i disagree that i think i i think
my experience
trying to be an experimentalist and i
failed at it
um um it was more experimental
biophysics x-ray crystallography
remember when i had that medicine
um and one of the things i saw was sort
of like
the there's there's theoretical work
also going on in this because you have
to now cleverly
um remember there was this one guy um in
our class
um he didn't stay around long but he
once said an expert a great
experimentalist is able to tease out
nature's secret
able to yeah reveal in her secrets right
yeah like this idea that like you know
they're these hidden things and
how do you just design a magic trick
right
yeah that's kind of like a really
brilliant experiment is
that you you have to now imagine and
theorize before you even
get on and build us the breadboard right
there's this kind of like
theorizing and figuring out okay how do
i fool nature
all right and how do i how do i rewire
nature
to reveal to reveal um the unseen
right um make it manifest so i think
that there is a very similar
um it's i think it's coming from the
same source really really brilliant
experiments
um i and i would love to see you right
your second book should be about
that should be about the genius of like
like you know we often talk about the
genius of how
feynman took the rock's um amplitude and
turned it into
the feynman path in the world like you
know let's talk about the genius of like
the pound replica experiment and like
these designs that
that like made theory real you know
when you i remember like when we were
grad students you go around the basement
my coffee
you're working on this very expensive
amplifier like
you're building an amplifier to look for
polarization in the cmb
like that's a pipe dream like 1994 right
1993
yeah that's right well you weren't alone
no none other than paul steinhardt said
we'd never detect it so
maybe he's right about b modes i don't
know i remember he gave a colloquium
when we were
you know first year student second it's
like why are you wasting your time with
this
yeah we do we do and i want to get into
some of the kind of creative aspects of
things that he explores
and you explore because i think he's
wrong
i want to uh talk about you know kind of
the difference between
between our um two fields you know of
experiment and theory
that uh that there isn't necessarily
conciliance between them because
uh you couldn't make a good living as a
theorist you know predicting things
uh you know i was talking to janna again
uh earlier
and you know thank you for stopping by
the podcast we had a crossover episode
which we'll uh put a link to where you
know it's like facts of life and
different strokes all got together
but uh remember that back in the day
what's happening and you know
we used to watch all those shows
together and now we had a crossover so
thank you for joining that
but you know we talked about like her
theories that i have a rerun of the
episode
yeah you want me to rerun oh no roger
that's a roger i'll say that uh the uh
the thing that we talked about was like
her theories you know of black hole
battery black hole
flashlights and uh you know topology on
the universe
on these massive scales that you know
really you could never expect to test in
fact her
previous book or her you know most
recent book she's writing another one
that'll be out later this year
but about the detection yeah she's
writing another book about black holes
and and how but the first book you know
about you know
the black hole blues book was really
brought to fruition as a success
only because of the discovery by an
experimental team
and one of the things i like to talk
about with mostly i've had on
theoretical physicists like jim gates
and sean carroll and um
katie mack and others that were on but
when i talk to
a theoretician i always like to get a
sense of
what they view as the value of
experiment in other words
is experiment merely you know the kind
of
confirmatory or you know refuting
evidence for a theory in other words
does experiment serve
theory or or is there another road is
there a different ground
that is intrinsically valuable because
obviously
you know you and i have great regard for
for the ancients and galileo
you know he didn't they didn't make a
distinction between a theoretical
physicist and experimental physicist
until
what the 1920s or something like that so
um so what do you make of that is is
experiment in the service of theory not
a negative sense but
is it in use only in service to kind of
prove or or
you know kind of validate physical laws
of nature that are produced by theorists
um yeah so my i've had a i've had an
evolution with regards to this if you
were to ask me this question 10 years
ago
i'd be like well i'm living in 10
dimensions and i'm trying to deal with
pure thought and trying to use
i'm trying to find the ground state of
string theory that will correspond to
our universe
which was something that i was working
on um and then
you know well you know that story and i
you know i managed to to do something
with that and then it turned out
that it all went to um it all fell into
the multiverse
um so i um
there are two things that changed my
direction um
one was a statement from bj bjorken um
the great particle physicist
who at some point like you know he's
responsible for the quark model of
you know and there's some particles
named after him and
he is uh a theorist of the highest order
and one of the great theories of the
last century
um theoretical part of his particle
physicist and when i was at slack as a
postdoc
he would always come around and like you
know ask us
trick trivia questions and one question
he would ask us was
because you know a lot of theorists got
attracted to theory because of einstein
and
and this idea that he came up with gr on
pure thought
so bj asked the question was like how
long after einstein discovered gr
did he apply his theory to the
perihelion of mercury
all right now my memory not may not
serve me but it's an order of a few days
all right and a lot of us were shocked
at that right so in other words einstein
had already known about certain
experimental facts that were problematic
that
he used to guide him towards this theory
it goes deeper than that my evolution is
actually
that you know these days i rely on
talking to experimentalists
to help my theoretical intuition all
right so actually
i engage in theoretical talk with
experimentalists
because i i so um and i think the
the big for me the big story in the
history of theoretical physics
is something called quantum feel fear
which is we
many people believe to be the mother
language of you know the standard model
is based on this language on quantum
field theory
and the idea of the field right now you
know in the 1800s a guy named
michael faraday you know as you know the
story
he is probably the greatest
experimentalist known and now
in physics um and faraday
to explain why it is that change in
magnetic fields will induce electric
currents far away from the magnet um
said there's going to be
he theorized that there were invisible
lines of force you know like woo-woo
stuff right
and he was the laughingstock of the
theorists
and that turned out to be actually the
paradigm of physics which is
the idea of that everything basically
are made up of fields
it came from an experimentalist it came
from the intuition of an experimentalist
um so again i think that you know for me
personally i you know
i was watching give you a good example
there was a conference that i saw that
you are a part of at the pyramid
institute
you are one of two experimentalists at
this conference it was like all about
like
you know you know the past hypothesis
and the empty you know the smallest of
entropy in the universe and
the up the arrow of time and you know
and everyone was saying all this stuff
all this fancy
ads cft and c and all the stuff and
and you actually i was watching this you
rose your hand you said
you know we're looking for
a new form of cp violation
and i was like wow the only the only
person that made
sense in terms of what in informed my
theoretical musings later on was what
you said
because the connection it got me
thinking about the connection between cp
violation
right cpt symmetry and a violation of t
but you're the one that came up with
that an experimentalist so i have very
strong feelings about like you know how
important it is
for at least my students i'm like
whatever opportunity you get you must be
talking to experimentalists
about your theory and and getting their
feedback yeah
have a kind of intuition that could be
very useful for you
yeah my father who was giving you in
terms of giving you
orientation and giving you direction
otherwise they're going to be lost in
like this jungle
yeah yeah my father you know was a great
mathematician
and he always used to say that actually
you me
i should know you know understand
theoretical physics
at the level comparable to a
theoretician
uh not necessarily at the level that i
have to create new theories although
i've tried to do that
unsuccessfully uh so far but i'll let
you know if that pans out
yeah exactly yeah mark kaminkowski at
johns hopkins you know used to call me a
deeply
closeted theorist but but anyway the the
thing that i
you know always took away from my
father's statement and this coming from
mathematician
was that to really uh to be a good
experimentalist you have to understand
why you're doing it you can't just be a
plumber
you know electrician and and you know
those are great things to be but in the
context of truly understanding why
you're doing it
and it's an obligation that i think a an
experimentalist has to understand the
theory otherwise they are just
merely you know kind of turning screws
and and so forth and not to again to
denigrate that at all
uh but but on the same token a theorist
doesn't necessarily have to understand
the ins and outs of the experiment but
if he or she does
uh it's a superpower and i think that
level
you know when you see people like that
that are intimately embedded
in experimental science uh something
like our friend
david spurgle yes he knows i mean he
could have been a great experimentalist
i mean he understands the d
yeah and he does numerical experiments
but he's uh one of the foremost
theorists of of his
uh generation and i think you know
people like him or robert dickey
you know also an eminent theorist a
brand sticky theory you know uh
the uh you know anthropic principle it
had precursor notion of inflation
flatness problems and so forth
and and then he was you know deeply
involved with experimental
searches for you know gravity and
obviously the cosmic background
background
um that uh you know he's indelibly
associated with
so i i always say and i and i like to
bring this up i had this conversation
with stephen wolfram and jan 11
and eric weinstein and it really
revolves around
what i think is physicists in general so
here we can agree that we're both
physicists
but that we kind of envy in a certain
sense the fact that mathematics
it can be proven that mathematics is
either incomplete
or incoherent in a sense girdle's
theorem basically
shows that and the closest i argue that
we have to
such a dictum in physics is
uh karl popper's falsifiability
criterion that's really called the
demarcation
that something which cannot be proven
wrong
is does not constitute science and
that's you know
no one made popper god right i mean uh
just because he and he had you know he
had his predilections he was a big
believer in the steady state theory
uh for a long time and uh because he
thought that was sort of occam's razor
in a sense explanation so i wonder you
know do you think that physicist will
ever have something that
really is elevated to the level of a
girdle in completeness theorem
or is it is it just destined to uh
really be some combination of occam's
razor
and and karl popper's demarcation
hypothesis
yeah i think i mean you i think you're
asking the question of the ages
i mean that's a i don't have i would say
that the closest i've come to
to so i've i've asked similar questions
and i ask it
these days because some of the things
that i'm working on or
even the new research research
directions that i might be taking
um you know is
really i think is is inspired um by that
challenge actually that you just
raised um i want to read you a quote
that
i think that that helps couch that that
that
those questions actually yeah and gives
me some
some kind of direction or inspiration or
solace um um to kind of maybe humble me
and it's from albert einstein so like
and i think it was the 30s
he was at oxford university and people
were still trying to figure out
how did you crack the code how did you
figure it out how did you come up with
general relativity like you know
like how did you get that insight that
space is right
temporal field equations right and this
was his response
you know and he's obviously speaking a
little bit of parables right so he goes
i'm quoting here a new idea comes
suddenly and in a rather intuitive way
that means it is not reached by
conscious logical conclusions
but thinking it through afterwards you
can always discover the reasons
which have led you unconsciously to your
guests
and you will find a logical way to
justify it
albert einstein hmm very interesting i
was like you know you got this into you
know whatever he had this
i mean i'm just curious how how you
think that that
that you know by me um sidestep into
albert einstein
yeah well yeah that's the last refuge of
the scoundrel is to invoke albert
einstein but
um you know uh yeah i've had that exact
same kind of
thought that you know and don't forget
einstein you know worked in the patent
office it's no secret
right he was deeply influenced by you
know swiss
uh kind of uh you know his swiss
heritage or up
you know at least formative years there
and at eth and
in switzerland and and seeing the
culture of time keeping and precision
that was really manifest at that time
and also you know never forget the kind
of deep realizations he had what did he
call his deepest tool as most important
tool
he called them thought experiments
gedanken experiments right
so he was an experimentalist it was just
a thought experiment
and i wonder if nowadays you feel like
we're kind of lost in math as our mutual
friend
sabine haasenfelder who'll be a guest on
the show not too long from now
um how she you know really makes this
claim that theoretical physics has been
you know basically stagnated for the
last uh what does she call
basically our whole lifetime since the
70s
and she claims that you know really the
stagnation is the result of
uh really a fascination with the with an
obsession with beauty
and with with finding mathematics uh
you know to be elegant and beautiful and
and there have been books you know
brian green actually named the elegant
universe uh
your book makes a lot of parallels
between not visual arts but
but um but you know the musical arts
jazz obviously it's a huge part of it
and
she claims that this you know is kind of
treading over ground
that hasn't borne fruit in 40 years so
let me let me get your take on this and
eric weinstein our mutual friend
also has had made significant claims of
that nature on this very podcast and
elsewhere
that we're either very bad salesmen and
sales women
and that we're not really promoting how
awesome theoretical physics has been
or there really hasn't been the greatest
turnover and new ideas
since the you know november 1975 uh kind
of red particle revolution
where do you stand in that uh in that
kind of
it's a very you're asking all these hard
questions yeah well
what do you expect we're coming on this
podcast that's why i'm paying you so
much
that's your honorarium brother okay hook
me up
um um
so i think it's it's it's a very
interesting intention
i mean because at one level so far like
you know when we look at our standard
model of particle physics right
here we have this this lagrangian and
you specify
like you know so my one of my great
mentors john collins particle physicist
um john collins he said he had a final
exam question for his part in his
quantum field theory
um advanced quantum field theory class
and the question was if i give you
lorenzen variants
um sc2 sc3 and u1 and
gaussian variants and four dimensions
there's only one unique lagrangian to
write down write the lagrangian down
right and it's a standard model without
without the higgs term and that kind of
stuff right
that you can uniquely specify a theory
that like you know
that we've just you know tested you know
to
you know great great lengths right i
mean so so
at one level you know we see a passion
at least you know the incredible what's
that vigne quote
the um the unreasonable effectiveness of
mathematics
so i think that that statement kind of
codifies however
it reminds me of um one a great jazz
musician arnold coleman who's
he's was also a mentor and a friend of
mine and i once bought um
a great you know a great musical a
researcher in cognitive science ani
patel
to come down to meet on a coleman and he
had all these questions for annette
you know all these technical questions
about music theory and harmonics and all
this stuff
and he goes on with these questions
and ornette goes i'll answer if you can
tell me where an idea comes from
right and it was like okay maybe it was
a cop out but you know
well taken i think this points back to
the albert einstein thing
yeah you know we have this beautiful map
that we can then use as a tool and it
can be very efficiently used to make
predictions and calculate outcomes
that another language may may not be
able to do
um but you know can you write down an
equation for in
for the intuition that got you that that
insight that got you that math
um you know and the source of the
creativity or you know just basically
physical what about
what about physical intuition what about
the fact that you know you and i know we
have um
i mean like david like david is that
david sparkles like that right
you know like david would have like a
crazy intuition
he he once told me something uh you know
um three years prior was like an
intuitive thing
i went back and i did the calculation
for like two years and he was bang on
correct
how do you explain that right right yeah
dance there's this interesting thing
there right and it goes back to this
other thing about what einstein said you
know it which is like
the most incomprehensible thing about
the universe is that it's at all
comprehensible
you know what is what is it about the
human mind and us that's able to come up
with this stuff
what's the math what's the physics of
that you know
yeah um and like so anyway i i
i think that it's a dance it's sort of
like yes nobody takes away from
the ma but you know you and i your dad
um was a great mathematician
and he once told me a story that he said
that he used to tell you
when um which was if anybody you know
like you know math is people
will try to impress you with math and
but what's a number
like this question right what's a number
right one time i was
uh in i was in some space with these i
was at the institute of advanced study
on sabbatical and all these brilliant
mathematicians and they're giving me a
hard time making fun of me of like this
you know you physicists you stumble on
something
and we come to clean it up and then i
said to one of them
what's a number and then he completely
got like
he did not know how to respond to that
so
like anyway so i can go on for days
i don't have an answer to your question
but i do believe that
it's sort of like you know the whole
elephant thing that one party elephant
yes
seems like mathematics is a good tool
but
not all mathematics seems like a subset
of the math
can be useful and a subset
you know of the math is just useful to
mathematicians and um
and some of the some of it is useful to
economics and some of it is useful to
machine learning
but to say that math is going to be the
thing the guideposts and the the holy
grail
that will give us um give us the
breakthroughs in physics
that i disagree with right i think
especially when you when you look
explicitly at it for guidance
via elegance beauty you know obviously
there are people on one extreme like uh
like paul dirac and
maybe eric weinstein cleaves to that
mold
that is you know dirac used to say it's
more important that your equations be
beautiful that your math is beautiful
then it'd be right
obviously he was right and he actually
made predictions about the physical
world
more often than he was wrong but i
wonder was there attention
you know as you're writing this book the
fourth anniversary of which is now upon
us the jazz of physics
and you're talking about the secret link
between the structure of the universe
and i wonder if you could take us
through what was the inspiration when
did you realize first of all
that you had to write a book that you
because you used to say to me like don't
write a book
unless you cannot not write a book like
basically you gotta
have and you encouraged me you said you
have the story you connected me and the
right people in the right the right
times and
and i couldn't have done it without you
but really i was always
nervous like do i have enough of an idea
and
when did you know unequivocally that you
had a
you had this idea for this brilliant
book that would go on to be a bestseller
and
influence both you know it's like
sometimes people to do to try to do too
much
you said multitasking is not your strong
suit but you try to do something for the
jazz community and then they're going to
say oh you're not a real jazz musician
and you try to do something physics well
you dabble in jazz so
was that a fearful process for you i
mean you already had tenure right but
but how did you how was it for you when
you knew you had to write this book
and what fears did you have to overcome
and limitations self-limitation did you
have to overcome
in order to bring it to life another
again another card question
yeah the ivy league professor man
um yeah well i mean i think like you
know looking back at it because
sometimes you do things you know
you're not even aware of what the
impulse was so
um but looking back i realized i did i
wrote the book i had to write the book
for mainly two reasons the first reason
was
um i wanted to write the book for a
younger version of myself
so in other words when i was like some
you know
some you know some young lost soul that
may have like had my fantasies you know
my naive fantasies about
about being a scientist and um
especially physics
and and you know being a musician and
not not wanting to really give up on
either
and and not knowing how to reconcile
those um
inner inner conflicts of of identity
actually if not
actually it's it's also about that that
that nerd from the bronx that really
didn't fit in and
and like you know had this these two
passions and couldn't find
that outlet anywhere either you're the
cool musician or you're an early
scientist and i was
i was sort of like in the closet about
both of those things
and i felt like you know i had reached a
certain level of like you know
i kind of knew how to play my horn i
knew something about music um
and i knew something about physics and i
was like start to see
ways in which those two worlds um were
were linked and um i just said you know
i'm gonna write this book i have to
write this book but i have to write the
book to clarify some of those things
so it was actually a process of like you
have this this sort of
inner intuition and the process of
writing the book and telling those
stories
helped me clarify and also reconcile
some of those conflicts that i actually
had and it was the process of coming out
of the closet as well
and making it known to people who i was
afraid of and i was afraid would judge
me
to say you know what this is who i am
and this is what this is this is the
story
and and you know you saw the book of
some of the book reviews i got some of
them were not
some of them were people who were
threatened by that and they were like no
you know you're just a physicist trying
to be a musician and you're or you're
just a
fake physicist viewing music i was like
maybe i'm neither of those things how
about that you know like
right you know i am like right in the
store this is my this is this narrative
and so um so for me it was kind of both
of those things
the process of trying to clarify
something by
by by writing and telling those stories
and then and also
you know kind of like writing that book
for
for a kid for a young person or a person
you know
that writing a book for somebody that
that would find
such a book very useful or inspirational
yeah and i think it has i mean you were
able to communicate to people i remember
you telling me
and you know wait till you start getting
you know emails from people around the
world
and you know and i've gotten that i've
gotten people you know some guy in
pakistan
uh you know it's just like i'm your
biggest fan
and you know he's probably muslim and
here i am this new york jew you know
and like we couldn't be farther apart
and you know i'll get emails about that
and it's i think in large part because
you encouraged me that the story has to
come out if you don't let it out
you know i'm glad you did it why it's
funny you're gonna now see the blessings
actually
coming out soon because you have
you you're also a pioneer because the
very thing that you were
um that you were there's fairness as you
know
i knew that when you were writing one of
there was this
fear let's face it like all right i have
to i have to come out and say
you know speak about my spirituality and
and the veracity of my signs and you
know and
in the same breath in the same book and
i remember that there was
there was you know um you know what
happens when you write books like this
and it turns out
a book it will soon be coming out that
i'm actually um
i'm re i have to take i have to read by
a very
very accomplished um um young physicist
i can't mention his name i can
and it touches on the similar topics
it touches on like you know this guy's
actually a rabbi as well as like
a top-notch theoretical um
biophysicist wow like he's talking about
and
it's so it's like aren't you glad that
you were the first to write such a book
well you know depart now wants to sell
themselves as like i'm writing the first
book of this nature where i'm making
this link in a way that's like
you cannot answer the question about
this unless you look at
this which we're told to not look at
right right you did it already
yeah well you know i think again you
know i don't want to turn this into too
much of a mutual admiration society but
but it's impossible when you bring your
friends on your part i know i know
that's right i'll uh
the university will forbid me from
bringing on buddies again but the uh but
the but the basic
truth they're hardcore
um you know for me thinking about what a
book is and at the end of the podcast
we'll ask you guys
we'll ask you the same questions i ask
everybody that comes on which is you
know the meaning of books and how they
affect you and it's exactly like you're
saying how it can
be this this letter almost as i call in
the book like an ethical will
where you give a you you have a book and
it's not really for you
i mean we'll talk about that later what
your legacy what you hope your legacy
will really
um amount to and and in terms of your
book and and maybe we could talk a
little bit
about um about your next project we'll
talk about that at the very end
but uh you know one of the things that
really spoke to me in this book is
a notion of gratitude and the gratitude
that you have
for teachers and as i you know i hope
there's nobody who speaks russian out
there
um in the in the wilderness listening
but the word as i was taught by my
teacher alexander polnarev who you knew
very well and great dogs
yes that's right i'm a great physicist
he is yeah
and having him as a mentor you know he
used to say scientist in russian
translates into
a person who was taught and you know in
your book you're talking about these
things and you're talking about at one
point you referenced my
uh your reference bruce partridge one of
your teachers and david wilkinson
who is my grand advisor so he's my phd
advisor peter timbe's
phd advisor and in my book i also show
my uh my academic genealogy stretching
back to the 1500s
and now one of my students darcy baron
is now she's a professor and now she is
a graduate student
at the university of new mexico so it's
like 20 generations and
how do you see yourself and this book
you know kind of
in the in that along that chain that's
unfurled
since you know in here in the ancients
going back to pythagoras etc
that you talk about all the way through
the future the resonances of the
universe how did that thesis play out
did it come to you
how did it the this inspiration we
talked about how the story emerged from
you the fears you overcame
but where did this idea come from or is
it like
you know einstein you just can't you
can't really pin it down
yeah i mean a lot of it came from
actually listening you know i
as you know i'm a big i'm an avid fan of
john coltrane
and um and you know and listen to his
the evolution of his
his sound his music he kind of like you
know
went from sort of like the more
traditional bebop hardbop
tradition and then he kind of went into
this other realm
where it was more an exploration of
sound
um so just not necessarily structured
notes and chord changes and
the way in which we you know might
traditionally think about music but
and you know culture is also like you
know even a love supreme
um or even like the more like you know
his album expression or you know um
cosmic sound right interstellar space
that's a great album by the way um every
every um every song is named after a
planet
in our solar system and and it's
fantastic
and it's just a different axis that you
know
that you have to listen and but it's
beautiful and it's capturing
but it's an exploration of sound so then
when i realized that actually
you know music what we call music and
also some of it
also had to do with the inspiration i
had from brian nino who was a friend and
a mentor
that i knew and i don't mean to name
drop but i you know i can't help myself
no i was
actually just going to read his blurb
this book could have just as well been
called the joy of physics
because what leaps out is stefan
alexander's delight and curiosity about
the cosmos
and how he finds pleasure in exploring
it brian eno artist composer and
producer
that's right and so brian was also that
kind of musician
which was that he played with sound you
know he basically was basically
injured um i guess he referred to
himself you'd do treatments when he was
a rock to music right
and sound synthesis and you know just
the science of sound
and i was like oh that's my hook i mean
here we have
you know sound and acoustics which is a
branch of physics
already so that's already a link and
then
then there's this remarkable crazy thing
which has you know
when we look at the expanding universe
jim peoples who won the nobel prize this
year
right uh wait was it last year this year
no 2019.
right jim peebles i mean there's a whole
chapter in the book about jim people's
discovery
before he got the nobel prize by the way
that's right you predicted it
and you know that prediction was that if
the universe is expanding
this is what's crazy right if the
universe is expanding
and only if the universe is expanded the
equation the equation for the plasma so
you have the expanding universe right
and it's filled with a plasma of hot
energetic electrons and photons
and it's all you know there's no
structure there but it's basically a
medium that can carry sound
and what people's basically showed is
that that
system literally is an acoustic system
and that the expansion rate itself set
the scale for the resonance so just like
you know how you have an instrument
and this the geometric size of an
instrument right
the size if i have a flute if you the
the the fundamental the largest the
longest frequency that can fit
right is basically the length divided by
fourth of that flute right
and a similar calculation what people
showed is that you're going to get these
sound waves
and these sound waves are responsible
for seed and structure
stars and galaxies and us and it started
with sound and of course there's a
beautiful resonance with the book of
genesis as well
instead of in the beginning was a word
it began with sound
right the beginning of our structure and
so like that to me
was just so compelling just like you
know that the modern jazz musicians and
modern
um composers like brian you know like
their
their direction and their music was more
about sound
and then you had like this fundamental
thing happening
in cosmology that the big question that
we asked
and the thing i was researching which is
structure formation in the universe
and that also had to do with sound and
that to me was my link
and then once i have that link and then
it became now
how far can i push these analogies and
the book was
also a book about analogies was a book
about the importance when we do
scientific research and scientific
inquiry
the importance of not getting it exact
and not having an exact mathematical
equation
but having a good analogy between two
systems
that actually are just analogous to each
other and then where they don't
completely overlap
it might give you a new direction for
you know for your investigation and to
discover something new
so yeah yeah so when i was talking with
eric weinstein a couple weeks ago
one of my listeners asked me to ask him
a question about
you know he said basically i've heard
eric describe
geometric unity which is his new theory
or not new but his proposal for
at least one venue to pursue that may
ultimately lead some
to some greater unification of of the
laws of physics and gravity as well with
the
uh three other uh four of the four
forces of nature
and this gentleman friend of mine said
uh i've listened to him on joe rogan's
show
a couple times i've listened to him on
lex friedman's show
and i just don't get it the way he
explains things i do not get it so
please ask him to
describe it in terms of analogies and i
think that's co and i don't know if i
succeeded so much in my interview with
him but
uh the listeners can be the judge of
that uh but but
that's one of the most beautiful aspects
of your book is
is that you are thinking in analogies
and like again i'm not you know
you know me when when i give you a
compliment you got to look out but
uh uh but yeah i'm your friendly
neighborhood grouchy
cosmologist right uh as you put it at my
and your wedding speech at my wedding
uh but the but the top heads off yes
but the truth is you know having this
ability to analogize i hate it when
people say can you dumb it down
you know because you can't dumb it down
and if you do
and and you told me this again another
piece of sage advice of the book don't
dumb it down
don't dump down your research don't
thumb down your physics because
what's important is that you the reader
feels like you respect him or her
and if you respect him or her then she's
likely to feel
trusted and and and trust you uh and
that you're taking uh him or her
seriously so
i thank you for that and the analogies
play really well and
the criticism you know i always say i
think it'll be a fun podcast tell me
what you think about this you know like
i think it'll be fun to have a podcast
where you have people who are
um who are verified purchasers and
they've read
your book my book you know whoever's
book and they gave it a one star review
and they're but they're not like just
trolls or being nasty
you know but like when people criticize
your book they say things like well
you know it's not really you know how
does the universe improvise
and that's not really the point that
you're trying to make you're making an
analogy and it's not like you're saying
let's revive pythagoras
go on yeah i'm not saying that's right
i'm not saying
a lot of people mistook they were like
when they bought the book they have
these high hopes of thinking
oh the universe revealed that the
universe is a jazz there's a jazz
musician playing the universe
yeah versus improvising that kind of
stuff
um that's not yet i wasn't trying no
it's very clear the subtitle is the
secret link okay so i could see people
getting a little woo-woo about the
secret
link but between the music and the
and the structure of the universe you're
talking about the structure that means
the large scale structure
the organization of the structure which
on large scales and you can correct me
if i'm wrong
but the large-scale properties of the
universe may in turn be determined by
its microstructure can you talk a little
bit about that
and how the very tiny can affect the
very large
yeah i mean if what if you allow me to
mean to talk about inflation in the car
yeah yeah yeah yeah so that's right i
mean you know one of the things that um
you know um again in like if you look at
people
like brian eno and you know people that
work in
electronic synthesis where you you know
you um you you play with sound you know
you manipulate sound waves
electronically right
um to create new sounds and actually
you know create entire compositions for
example um generative music is an
example of this
and actually if you look at um as an
analogy so you want say you want to
explain
cosmic inflation and the quantum theo
theoretic fluctuations of inflation
good luck to a lay reader right but here
i have
you know i can i can you know talk about
a synthesizer
and i can talk about you know that you
know every note is like basically a sine
wave
and i and it turns out that when i use
that analogy
it comes really really close
the universe is not a synthesizer but
you can really understand a lot of
cosmic of like of the fact that what
that during inflation
the early stages of the universe right
um
you know um you know 10 to the minus you
know 30
something seconds right um after the big
bang
you have basically um a period of
rapid expansion universe and that rapid
expansion of the space
space time of this um basically sets the
stage
such that it amplifies um
these quantum undulations it amplifies
them and stretches them
and those are the things and it does it
in a way where it's very democratic and
how it does it
so it creates basically something that
we call white noise
and everybody here as white knows what
white noise sound like it's basically
the hiss
that you hear with your if you had old
school tv sets
um but the basic point there is that you
know um
that's initial sound that initial sound
spectrum
um it's not literally sound it's the
sound of the vacuum if you want to call
it
um is you know is the thing that we
you know i think the current paradigm is
and it's consistent with the experiments
is the thing that source the large scale
structure in our universe today
um but you know going back that i can
explain a lot of that
not by saying that the universe is you
know playing a jazz chord
it isn't but it's a really it's really
impressive analogy
and you know i you know who i learned
this from actually i think who did it
the best was i'm richard feynman
and and it's because you know i felt
like to really make these analogies and
do well
you actually really had to understand
the
you know the subject matter deeply it's
really hard
to make to find a good analogy for
something unless you have it
well you could get lucky and you could
have good intuition i'm not saying it's
the only way
but i found it was the exercise of
finding these analogies really required
me to like
to understand the you know you know
quantum fluctuations a lot deeper than i
thought i'd understood it
just by writing down the you know the
creation and annihilation operators you
know
yeah right yeah and alienating your
authors i mean i think you know stephen
hawking said every equation
let me ask you that's one thing i also
believe that mathematics is also an
analogy
yeah you know if you have like a you
know like if i look at a pendulum and
it's going up and down i write down
you know a simple harmonic you know i
write down the oscillatory equation for
that
that's just an analogy yeah why else
would wigner say it's
unreasonable to the real thing right why
else would wigner say it's unreasonable
for math to be effective unless
it is only an analogy right it's a model
for
it's not the thing if we can't
understand what a number is
or you know it takes two books of proofs
to to show that one plus one equals two
too is it only a best imperfect
approach asymptotically to the notion of
of what meaning is uh in terms of a
mathematical description of physics and
galileo
you know is one of the first if you know
to to really and
invoke that and i think you know this
book
pays homage to them yeah so he was the
first you know he was a mathematician
his father
thought he should be a doctor uh you
know his father was a musician
and uh wanted his son to not you know
squander his talents and and
become a physician and so he didn't he
became a doctor but you know not the
kind that helps people like us
uh he became like us uh instead well i
want to ask you
uh i know you don't have too much more
time but i want to start um
you know kind of winding down this
particular episode we're going to do
many more parts i hope
um can you say anything about projects
that you're working on in the future
before we get to
uh the the the segment that i call the
final five which i ask all my guests but
in particular in research in jazz in
writing
can you take us on those three uh you
know kind of
trimesters or try try segments of your
brain
and uh where are you uh what what are
your plans in each one of those
three different uh areas well you know
actually
before i left lee leon was leon cooper
was my first thesis advisor
um and then i moved into cosmology and
what happened it's in my book but
it started off with back then leon was
doing uh machine learning like but
basically modeling
real prof he became a biophysicist soon
after his nobel prize
and i was working on in the early days
of machine learning with leon
um and i i the project back then that i
was working on was to
to look at the large-scale structure of
the universe using unsupervised
um um neural networks machine learning
yeah i remember that and i wrote that i
even i still have that paper i wrote in
1997 it was like a preprint that i never
put out
right it's really funny to see that
that's what people are working on today
um but i've i've returned back to some
of that
um but more of the theoretical level
trying to understand
you know what is it about the these the
architectures and what is this
you know it turns out there's certain
physical systems like
i don't want to give give too much of it
away that has a really close semblance
to the way
the machine learning architectures are
modeled mathematically
and looking at these physical models and
that and trying to understand whether or
not what
what can be gained on both sides of that
analogy
um another thing i'm working on is i've
been
leon after leon told me to find a real
project to work on
i decided to dedicate a lot of my after
tenure
so the last like i don't know 12 years
i've been working on the cosmological
constant problem
yep and i'm starting to make some um
some progress on that
you know that's led to this whole thing
about the multiverse and that you know
if the cosmological constant the vacuum
energy is exactly
not this value you can't have life in
the universe right that's not actually
exactly true
oh wow um yeah um
there's a paper i wrote with um with um
fred adams and grow
and um marcini halton we showed that if
you let
other coupling constants um float as
well
you can you can you can change the
vacuum energy by eight orders of
magnitude six orders of magnitude i
forget
and you still get habitable zones so
it's not as finely tuned as we're led to
believe
yeah and that that then gave me the the
the um
confidence to then really start leon
gave me an idea he said
there is a hidden symmetry at work and
it's not supersymmetry
that is dealing with the cosmological
constant and i think i found what that
is
and i've been working on that and it's
related to our good friend our you know
our friend and your
your um benefactor and and um
um jim simons um it's related to chern
simons actually um so i put up preprint
out recently it's up for review
it looks like it's going to get
published and it's a way of um
dealing with the vacuum energy
sequestering it into a topological
sector having to do with deterrent
simon's number
and what we're looking at now uh if we
have we have this theory it's a modified
theory of gravity
and we're looking right now to look to
see if there's solar system tests
that can constrain this theory so again
experiment
you know whether or not they're this
thing makes a
prediction that deviates from einstein's
relativity and you know either makes a
prediction and if it
if it whatever that is can we rule the
theory out you know that so that's kind
of
what i'm doing physics wise these days
other than that i'm pretty i'm pretty
confused
and and um and and
and directionless i'm i'm still also
trying to find what directions to go
into
so maybe you can um offline you and i
can talk about some of the secret
experiments you're doing
yeah we uh it's funny because you know
well max planck said that physics
advances one funeral at a time
but it was funny because i i sort of
mean i mean it in
a non-morbid sense by you know kind of
one paper at a time every every
generation you have to reinvent all the
literature
so one of my students is working on
looking at axions and time varying
signals
how they could be produced in the cmb
polarization or are discovered through
cmb polarization
and then our mutual collaborator in tel
aviv university mayor shimon
brought up that you had worked on a
similar effect you know but with
circular polarization and so
my graduate student you know now we're
in like the second almost third
generation
between all three of us and uh and we're
looking at you know how can we constrain
you know circular birefringence and uh
circular dichroism and things like
exotic
effects all in an effort to really
understand how did uh
you know how do these how can we
constrain such exotic
uh phenomena that may lead to violation
of the most sacrosanct laws of physics
lorenz
invariants time reversal cpt violation
etc etc so
uh yeah so even though we uh we don't
get that you know hang out under the
waterman street bridge
and and uh drink ocean's coffee very
often uh we're gonna do that
what about like obviously covet is uh
has put a crimp on a lot of your
performances but
uh you were very uh active in the in the
providence in boston new york jazz scene
any long long range plans or or things
on the horizon once
things return to normal or not yet yeah
so there's a film
so there's this um project so i've been
working with this um
this great basis um you know considered
to be
jazz times basis of the year melvin
gibbs
played jazz played it was the basis of
the rollins band i mean so melvin
jt lewis um the great drummer jt lewis
and dj logic
we recently did um a live
um street of like a a block
like sort of like performance of social
distance and
yeah what music looks like when you when
you social distance
and that will be released very soon this
um great filmmaker
cam kristen that i'm mispronouncing his
name so he's putting out a series um
soon and we will appear in that but no i
have not been playing out a lot
and i've mainly been just trying to get
you know practice when i can um
hopefully i'll emerge you know
like like you know sunny rounds in the
bridge right you know i emerge from the
bridge you know being able to play
twinkle twinkle little star a little bit
better a little bit better yeah my kids
will
appreciate uncle stefan performing even
even more frequently than pumpkin party
that's right great pumpkin uh last thing
is your in the visual arts before we
turn to the final uh segment here
um so you played a role in the film uh
wrinkle in time can you talk a little
bit about that and
uh what the if there's anything uh
coming up in that in that aspect of
stefan
no no um so um that was great fun i
learned a lot from that
um actually the thing that was
interesting there was that you know like
i work with their creative
team and like you know they're all about
like you know you need to you you need
to take psychedelics really be
you know quantum verse and i'm like i'm
okay you know
i don't know i don't need that i
actually in working on that film in like
you know
um a wrinkle in time and trying to
figure out how to build a test rack and
how to do it in a way that's not a corny
wormhole anymore
and you know all this stuff right yeah
yeah that's part of wormholes wormholes
peak we're at peak wormhole exactly like
you know
enough wormholes right
um and one of the things i learned
i actually you know it was interesting i
learned things about my physics
trying to explain physics to them right
yeah um
and um so no so the answer is
no however as you know i am the
president of a
you know an organization of um black
scientists
um the national society of black
physicists and one of the things that
i dream of doing you know um and we're
trying to do is to
create new platforms for our young
emerging scientists
and and so i think like some of those
platforms may start looking like you
know having
people kind of like in a very exciting
and natural and
you know organic way talk about their
science talk about
their lives and have interesting
conversations right
and um and i think that working with you
know
the great ava duvenay right and her
creative team for
england time gave me some ideas of how
to do that
and actually you know i'll i'll say my
last compliment to you
um you know listening to preacher brian
like you know give his sermons you know
definitely um
you know um have given me some other
tips as well
all right good enough well uh i will say
though that there was
there was an idea that i felt i got
ripped off on and i can't
yeah for reasons i can't come on you
can't you can't tease like that
no because i don't know man you know you
might have to like snip it out later on
all right all right all right but there
was another flag famous movie where they
use
a concept for time travel and that was
my idea
okay wow okay all right i'm not we will
talk offline about that we'll get our
i have the phalanx of lawyers in the
next room i can i can call him you know
um well thank you for calling me a
preacher i haven't you know been
associated with the catholic christian
church in a long time but but it's nice
to
always go back to my roots there
so the end of the talk i usually like to
bring up i call it
uh the final five and i like to bring
together
some themes across all the great
intellects that i am uh privileged and
blessed to interview such as yourself
and uh it's been you know it's been it's
been kind of a
a wonderful time in the last few months
being with my children with my wife etc
but it's been challenging and and part
of the way to get out of the
depression that's natural to feel on
occasion is to
engage with great minds and great books
and i thought back
as i was interviewing um sasha sagan who
is the daughter of carl sagan and andrew
and who's an amazing kind of more
artistic and
and not as obviously scientifically
astute as carl sagan but nevertheless
has made so many contributions to
culture and popularization of science
so when i interviewed sasha i brought up
the fact that her father
said in an episode of the original
cosmos
series in 1980s there was an episode
called the persistence of memory so i'm
going to read it like him
what an astonishing thing a book is it
is a flat object
made from a tree with flexible parts on
which are imprinted lots of funny dark
squiggles and and equations and
graphs and all sorts of cool goodness in
this book
um but one glance at it and you're
inside the mind
of another person maybe somebody dead
for thousands of years
never thought about this across the
millennia an
author is speaking clearly and silently
inside of your head directly to you
and i think it's uh he says a book is
proof that humans are capable of working
magic
what i want to ask you is he talked
about you know millennia ago a book
could have been written
that influenced you um obviously you're
studied in the arts of
of uh of you know pythagoras etc and
you look at the ancient scrolls and and
its original parchment and
papyrus but uh i want to talk about that
magical aspect of
books and whether or not you stefan
alexander
high professor of uh hi solomon
professor of
of of uh physics at brown university if
you had your choice you could only
choose one don't say both
i'll get you if you do but would you
rather have a hundred readers of your
book the jazz of physics
next year or one reader a hundred years
from now
i'm one reader 100 yes or no okay
okay anyone i want to elaborate on that
no because i think this idea of it um i
mean i'm thinking about
i'm thinking about like a book i read
recently um
that you know i think the book was
written maybe in the 40s so it's not
quite 100 years ago
but just again like this it was it was
that much more special
that it was written at that time it was
a different time of you know
a different time um in our century um
and it was schrodinger's what is life
yeah i remember you
you you gave that to me in uh second
year grad school
oh wow well i never returned it i never
returned it so that's where your copy
you know what it's worth now signed by
exactly one million dollars okay
but um yeah so i but i think like you
know
you know reading that book and just
knowing actually just knowing that
schrodinger
wrote that book back then has you know
it does have this impact
yeah awesome okay next question that i
ask uh again about
breeders of your book the jazz of
physics now in its
fifth year it's uh finished uh four
years of or four orbits around the sun
with this wonderful uh wonderful book on
it
uh what do you have as a preference for
readers now this
again is not a hater troll uh you know
someone who's flaky who just doesn't
like stuff on
this is somebody who's engaged with the
book read it cover to cover maybe twice
uh would you rather have someone who's
skeptical of the notions that there is a
secret link between physics and the
structure of the cosmos
or would you rather have it be a fanboy
a fan girl that just
loves the ideas just like really into it
who would you rather have
really deeply thoroughly meaningfully
engage with your book
someone who's skeptical okay right good
because i'm skeptical about that too
yeah i think that's the
most honest way that a scientist can be
about uh certainly about his or her work
in in in science remember feynman said
you know the first principle is that you
must not fool yourself
and you are the easiest person to fool
so we sort of should be adversarial with
each other scientific ideas
but a book like ours that you know might
be a polemic um
yeah so it's great to hear your uh your
feelings there
okay i've always seen you as a boolean
optimist um
what are you pessimistic about anything
to do with the future of education
postcovid
um anything that you're pessimistic
about okay so i'm a contrarian as you
know so what are you pessimistic about
as an optimist
good uh yeah yeah that's a good question
um
i'm yeah i don't know if the word
i don't know how to how to word it but
like you know but it's sort of like
i know there's a faint there's another
einstein quote and he goes
you know we have a one einstein quote
per
episode minimum maximum sorry no i'm
just kidding einstein didn't say
uh brother said it feinstein weinstein
weinstein said this yeah um actually i
think weinstein actually did say this
quote i'm sure
there's two things in the two things
that are infinite
the universe and um human stupidity
and and then i think einstein goes on to
say
i'm not certain about the universe but
it's
again like you know when i say that i'm
also including myself in this i'm also
including my stupidity as well
i am i am part of that human family and
i think this uncanny ability for us to
just
you know sometimes you know make stupid
choices and do stupid things
when they are clear um the clear
smart thing to do and it's it's in front
of us and we choose
to make a super choice and i think that
there are certain things i'm being now
very general but now let me
make it specific i think that you know i
hope that in this next the next hour
this sort of new generation of
of thinkers and scientists and people
who are going to do
competent things and brave things that
they are truly rewarded
for for their innovations and not held
back because they may be different in
them they may think different or look
different or talk different right
and they don't fit into the social
structures or what have you
that they're going to be rewarded for
their innovations because we have
i i'm seeing especially here at brown
i'm seeing a new generation of
truly brilliant young people they're
just different
and we have to be ready for them and be
ready to
to elevate them and and give platforms
to them
and protect them and at the same time
and teach them at the same time but
definitely
acknowledge them and and um and reward
them even if they're different
and you know and and i'm also referring
to like
things like you know when um people from
underrepresented groups and women in in
the sciences
um who are thinking might be thinking
differently and coming up with
innovations
that we should um as a community um
really
um make the smart choices by um
celebrating their innovations yeah well
that really pains me to admit how
beautifully eloquent that was said about
it i learned it all from you bro
yeah i don't know about that um all
right last question
revolves around the telescope so
saron kierkegaard as you know once said
that life can only be understood
backwards
but you must live it forwards and you
know we astronomers look through
telescopes and we see things at great
distances that were
only produced very long ago and so we
might have clarity about what that
system used to look like we have no idea
what it looked like now but what i'm
asking you now
really refers to the name of this
podcast which is one of
uh sir arthur c clarke's three laws so
one of his laws was the only uh
the oh i'll say the first one is uh
um that any sufficiently advanced
technology
is indistinguishable from magic that was
his first law uh his second law
i'll just call it the second third one
second but the second law was
for every expert there's an equal and
opposite expert
but the third law is where we get the
name of this podcast from and he said
the only way to find out what is
possible is to venture beyond a little
bit
into the impossible so uh as the you
know co-director of the arthur c
clarke center for human imagination i
want to ask you looking back
through kierkegaard's telescope what
things
seemed impossible to you as a 20 year
old as a 30 year old
um that now seem possible because you
have that courage to venture into the
impossible
oh wow um you know i thought the thing
that was impossible that i mean
i never i was
i was so um i was so convinced that i
wasn't going to make it as a as a
scientist as a physicist
in terms of being able to have a career
in a profession
let alone tenure and what have you um
that i just went along with for the ride
just expecting you know
well this year i'm not going to make it
and this year i'm not going to make it
and i so
it never was like i have to make it and
get tenure and do this and do that
right it was more like you know i'm
going to continue doing this as long as
i
i'm allowed to and then when i fall off
the cliff i'll just you know
do something else right so at that 20
year old
person i thought it was impossible that
i was going to make it
to where i'm at right now professionally
and another thing was
as a theorist and i i and this still
lives with me
i think the dream of a theorist for me
of this theorist
is to actually have a be part of a
theory or be part of an idea
that actually finds it finds a home in
an experiment
that actually manifests itself to be
correct
um it says something about the real
world our world
right um because all of us all theorists
were wrong okay everything we publish
unless it's experimentally confirmed
okay it meets a certain theoretical
standard
tentative gold standard of actually it
being you know
um the detection of well you know all
the all the things that um were
experimenting confirmed
um that had been predicted higgs boson
that jerry growly played a big role in
right when we were practicing
that's right our professor yeah oh yeah
so the point is that like that to me is
still
still feels impossible but it feels
possible so long as i'm not so long as i
continue
kind of keeping it humble and talking
and actually
you know yeah and and and continuing to
talk
to to experimentalists because i think
that you guys kind of whole
give us the orientation and the
direction and the intuition sometimes
to to not get lost in that jungle
well that's really phenomenal well
stefan i want to thank you
again i owe you another coffee someday
i'll buy it from oceans coffee roasters
you can just buy my own coffee um estate
okay yeah well yeah well i'll put in a
requisition for that
uh i want to thank you we'll put in your
website your twitter handle we'll add
all that in
uh thank you for your generosity of uh
of spirit your honesty uh vulnerability
and also your insights and i want to
also recognize you
as the uh as the leader as the president
of the national society for black
physicists
which uh which i am honored to be an
honorary member of to be redundant
and i'm looking forward to many big
things that we can do together
to advance the you know story tradition
of this wonderful entity that you're
that you're uh charged with being an
intrepid leader of so
i want to thank you for your service to
physics to the community
uh to all of us really and we we have a
great uh debt to you and i cannot wait
to see what you come up with
next in your indomitable improvisational
um epicurean i'll stop at the
superlatives here because uh
you know otherwise you'll get a big head
thank you so much stefan alexander
uh thank you again for sharing your time
thank you mr brian king dr brian keaton
and
i look forward to seeing you soon
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
if you enjoyed this episode of into the
impossible please subscribe
comment share rate and review for a
chance to win a free copy of our most
recent guest's newest book
send a screenshot of your review to info
imagine.ucsd.edu
we appreciate hearing from you and are
always open to your suggestions for
future episodes
for more information go to
imagination.ucsd.edu
find us on twitter at imagineucsd
watch us on youtube listen on itunes
into the impossible is a production of
the arthur c clarke center for human
imagination in the division of physical
sciences
at the university of california san
diego
eric very director brian keating
co-director
patrick coleman associate director
produced by
stuart volcko